[Music]
good morning John it's Friday September
21st
for some reason they cut out the
beginning of that sentence and so I had
to add a nominator sorry and I'm sitting
outside of Missoula was beautiful City
Hall it's a kind of field trip I like to
it on to the City Hall every once in a
while
specifically when I get tickets that's
right I got a ticket I got a ticket for
not stopping at a stop sign while I was
on my bicycle and I'm not saying that
that was a smart move or anything but
I'm saying actually knowing I have to go
downtown and sit in courtroom one and
listen to people get lectures about duis
and drug busts and that kind of stuff
when I didn't stop at a stop sign on my
bike they said it was gonna be 81
dollars but then they decided that it
would only be ten so that was nice
um but a little bit of waste of time in
my opinion couldn't the guy have just
said give me ten dollars and I would
have given him ten dollars and then it
would have been a little bit more like
highway robbery but also a lot more
convenient I was going to take a lot
more b-roll inside of the City Hall but
it turns out that there are a lot of
college-age young women who probably
don't want YouTube to know that they got
a DUI but honestly it was upsetting for
more than just the inconvenient aspect I
mean yeah it sucked I had to wait there
for like an hour and a half so the judge
could tell me you do know that it's
illegal to not stop at a stop sign on
your bike and I could be like yeah I
have a ticket to prove that to me I know
because I got a ticket because a cop
pulled me over with the boom boom boom
so yes I know that it was illegal but it
was also kind of uncomfortable because I
walked up there and he was like ten
dollars please but everybody else in
that quorum was about to find out how
many hundreds or thousands of dollars
they were going to be fine for their
various infractions of drunk and
disorderly conduct or driving under the
influence or underage drinking most of
the things had to do with drinking
actually I've never been in a courtroom
for something that I did before to be
there amongst people who were there for
stuff that actually mattered and then to
walk up to deal I guess I will give you
$10 tip like I was intruding on a
serious world with a not serious thing
anyway on a completely different note
babbles this Monday Kathryn and I went
in picked apples this is something that
you get to do for free in Missoula
because there are so many apple trees in
the rattlesnake Valley
need to be picked or else they will be
attacked by bears and then the Bears
will get shot or hit by cars and that's
bad so you have to pick all these apples
so Catherine and I got called out to
volunteer and we got to pick apples and
we also got to take a bunch home so we
have cider and a big box of apples some
of them look pretty bad but some of them
look very good and of course apple pie
Catherine made three delicious looking
apple pies and so far it has been
somewhat difficult to not eat them but I
will get D with them soon so it is ok
you might think that you pick apples um
I was under the impression that you
picked apples but if you're in a hurry
as we were you just grab the tree and
you shake it shake it and the apples
just fall off and then you pick up the
apples off the ground for the higher
limbs
you're gonna ladder with a stick and you
hook the lid with the stick and sheep
stick and then you fall off the back of
the ladder or very nearly so it was very
fun but if you have a gleaning program
where you live that's what that means
gleaning means free fruit free apples
free apricot free plums free pluots plop
plop is a good word free they just they
come out of the tree and they're there
and when you eat them and they're
delicious and the people who have them
in the yard they don't want them they're
like get these out of my yard so that
the bear doesn't eat my dog what a world
John we are going to see they might be
giants on Sunday and I'm going to try
and smuggle this video camera right here
in to there and get a little bit of
footage but it's possible that they
won't let the camera in so I'm sorry no
guarantees John I'll see you on Monday